Hola el mensaje es no podemos perder más
tiempo así lo dijo el secretario general
de Naciones Unidas Antonio Gutiérrez Y
es que como usted lo adelantaba hace 46
años no se realiza esta conferencia y la
Primera y última fue en mar del plata
Argentina y es que no se puede perder
más tiempo porque estamos justo en la
mitad del decenio de la acción por el
agua que va de 2018 a 2028 y también
estamos en la mitad de la agenda 2030
que traza los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible de aquí al 2030
que es uno de los dos países con
anfitriones de esta conferencia señaló
que existen dos razones que están
poniendo el agua en riesgo la primera de
ellas es la crisis climática Y puso de
ejemplo que mil de los 14.000 glaciares
que había en su país ya no existen se
derritieron por el calentamiento global
y otro dato tres de cuatro desastres
naturales tienen que ver con el agua la
segunda razón que pone en riesgo el agua
es el crecimiento de la población Y es
que la última vez que se hizo esta
conferencia en Argentina existía la
mitad de las personas que hoy por hoy
habitan el planeta un mensaje que dio el
rey de Países Bajos William Alexander y
que es el segundo país con anfitrión él
dijo pocas veces una conferencia de la
ONU ha despertado tanto interés Y es que
según los datos de Naciones Unidas Hay
seis mil quinientos participantes
inscritos estos sin contar las personas
que vienen como representantes de estado
o que hacen parte de Naciones Unidas lo
cual indica todo un hito y que piden
Aquí también una acción acelerada para
proteger el agua dice Naciones Unidas
que esta es la conferencia de toda una
generación mana clara que es el diseño
de acción y por qué Porque es el destino
de acción por el agua y Por qué es
importante
este diseño de acción por el agua es
importante porque traza los compromisos
de los países de empresas de acciones
Civiles para poder proteger el agua y es
que justo Un día como hoy en 2018 un 22
de marzo que es cuando se celebra el Día
Mundial del agua la ONU convocó a los
países para que trazaran esos
compromisos voluntarios esto para
cumplir no solo el decenio sino también
los objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
especialmente el objetivo número 6 que
tiene que ver con agua limpia y
saneamiento Y es que como lo dijo
Antonio Gutiérrez El agua es la savia de
la humanidad porque tiene que ver con
todo sin agua potable no podremos tener
una seguridad alimentaria sin agua
potable tampoco habrá salud y tampoco
podrá haber equidad Y es que ocho de
cada diez personas que no tienen acceso
al agua viven en lugares Rurales esto
muestra como la falta de agua po impacta
ya a los que ya son más vulnerables y
cada año mueren 800.000 personas por
falta de agua potable o de condiciones
higiénicas apropiadas por eso es
importante este decenio para poder
alcanzar las metas de agua potable y
saneamiento para todos como se lo traza
también la agenda 2030 por eso el año
pasado en 2022 se reunieron los países
en dusan B la capital de tayikistán y
allí crearon la agenda de acción por el
agua que es donde ponen todos los
compromisos para cumplir este decenio y
para cumplir la agenda 2030 de esta
conferencia de la ONU se espera Entonces
que se nutra esa agenda aunque los
compromisos son voluntarios